I suppose the obvious analogy for Obama
would be Richard the second I don't buy
it myself I think Obama's a stronger
president than Richard the second was a
king but a man who is perhaps
politically naive who is perhaps too
cerebral for the world of assorted
politics you could make a case for it I
could see Obama as Hamlet a man given
two great cerebral self-examination who
finally realizes he has to act I don't
see Obama's Richard the third the way a
lot of people cast Richard Nixon is
ripped at the third I don't seem Obama
as Macbeth although I think Macbeth when
you go back to it is every ambitious
person or at least someone with the
grains of ambition who can be
manipulated by an ambitious person that
you've ever known I'm the thing for me
about Shakespeare is that you know you
see these people standing around the
water cooler I work with a dozen Iago's